there are over 1 million volcanoes on
our ocean floor and all of them suddenly
started spewing out red hot molten rock
the ocean is filling with lava and
nothing can prepare you for the
devastation to come
but why would the water become toxic
how would Earth change shape
and what would happen to the coastlines
around the world
this is the six things that would happen
if all underwater volcanoes exploded at
once
[Music]
many volcanoes sit atop shifting
tectonic plates building pressure over
years before they're ready to blow
scientists estimate that four out of
five volcanic eruptions happen
underwater
but for this to be truly apocalyptic
we'd need to wake up volcanoes that have
been dormant for over 10 000 years
you'd see the most activity in the
Mid-Atlantic as these waking Giants rip
the planet apart
but underwater volcanoes don't really
erupt in Epic explosions
instead they scatter lava across the
ocean floor
rocking the submarine landscape
as more than one million underwater
volcanoes spew out lava in the water
that water would become acidic
all thanks to the devastating amount of
carbon dioxide coming from eruptions
sea organisms would die off quickly in
this harsh environment and this is where
the food chain would break
but how would this affect life above
water
the lava would build and build creating
new land masses that would Tower over
the waves
we might see Islands pop out of the
oceans everywhere
experts think that this is the process
that gave us Iceland 70 million years
ago
but if the magma didn't keep flowing
these newly formed Islands could be
slowly lost to erosion from the wind and
waves
anything that withstands this constant
erosion would be covered in Ash
usually each of these islands hosts a
variety of life
the highlands play a vital role as
natural resting places and breeding
grounds for migratory Birds
and new microscopic life could thrive in
the volcanic soil but if every
underwater volcano was constantly
erupting non-stop all that Ash would
stop both birds and organisms from
finding a home in these areas
and the devastation wouldn't end there
the poisonous compounds would be spread
across entire regions and over
continents
in 2009 an eruption in the Tonga
archipelago rocketed Ash to an island
over 63 kilometers away
even worse with the pressure released
from all these volcanoes erupting
tsunamis could rise and devastate
coastlines
Burns so hot following its 2021 eruption
that it blazed a crater into the ocean
floor
it also triggered a tsunami that flooded
the islands of Tonga in minutes with
over 18 meters of water
Every Nation surrounded by water would
face the same risk during these violent
Global eruptions
maybe you'd be safer inland
right
meanwhile underwater landslides could
also destroy ocean life
all the rock and Ash being sprayed out
would change the face of the ocean floor
and the boiling Waters would cook marine
life and their charred remains would
float to the surface as an ominous sign
of the dangers below
landslides would also destroy Island
populations around volcanic chains
if the ancient submarine volcano known
as marsili located in the Mediterranean
collapsed during the eruption it could
be disastrous
the tsunami generated could flood the
coastlines of Italy
that's just one volcano
and all that tectonic energy released
would mean even more earthquakes and
tsunamis worldwide
look no matter where you live you may
not be safe in this new world
each continent could be destroyed From
Below as the plates shift during the
eruptions
cities far inland could feel the effects
as mountain ranges bulldoze entire
regions and deserts are flooded
but what if you traveled to an even more
dangerous planet
well keep watching because that's a
story for another
what if
foreign
[Music]